[Music]
at first it is barely noticeable among
the millions of points of light that
crowd the sky
this area of space is far from dark
illuminated as it is by the light of a
million stars crowding a hundred million
times more densely than they do around
the earth
a central cluster of suns wheel around
at an incredible pace spiraling towards
a singular static point of light the
center of their and every other star's
orbit
and it is here where the oddness of this
central body begins to reveal itself
instead of a smooth circle of light in
the crosshairs the object appears as a
vast glowing ring cross-cut just below
the equator filled at its center by a
black deeper even than the surrounding
nothingness
and it is now you realize this is the
black hole
but it is not just any black hole
this is the supermassive black hole at
the center of our galaxy
sagittarius a star up to this point you
have been propelled towards this curious
body under your own power but there now
begins a subtle tug towards it
you find yourself in an orbit around its
middle along with a glowing band of
accreting material which is lensed into
a halo by intense gravity within the
accretion disk you're pounded and
pummeled by fast moving gas dust and
debris and intense frictional heating
causes the entire disc to radiate at
high energy blasting your body with
x-rays and gamma rays your dna is
damaged beyond repair
but soon
that won't matter
it is at this point
reality starts to strain
from the perspective of a distant
observer the closer you approach to the
inner edge of the disc the slower you
seem to fall but as far as you're
concerned time is passing normally
now even if you could escape everyone
you know and their distant descendants
are already dead
[Music]
and it isn't just time that warps
assuming you approach the black holes
gaping more feet first then your lower
body will be experiencing a stronger
gravitational pull than your head your
entire body begins to distort although
the effect isn't as severe as it could
be a supermassive black hole like
sagittarius a-star only has a moderate
gravitational gradient compared to their
smaller stellar counterparts
this continues until after an observer's
eternity your feet hips and finally head
cross the event horizon
[Music]
passing this point is the end of your
time in the wider universe
beyond the event horizon the gravity is
too strong to let light or any signal
you may survive to send escape
[Music]
you
are shut off
forever
inside everything is turned on its head
time and space trade places and beyond
the event horizon it is time itself that
pulls you down towards the center no
force in the universe can stop this just
as nothing can stop the flow of time
itself what you experience inside no one
can say and certainly not you even if
impossibly you survived irradiation
spaghettification and the aging of the
universe then your voice would be
forever silenced by gravity itself
all that is left is the slight mass
increase of the leviathan that consumed
you a mass increase that will only help
your captor pull in more victims
such is the fate of anyone or anything
unlucky enough to fall into the mouth of
a black hole
first mooted in 1783 the
incomprehensible horror of these
ultimate galactic predators has captured
the imagination of scientists and pushed
the boundaries of science for decades
indeed the supermassive variety are
thought to reside at the center of every
galaxy and may well be the agents of
their creation
while black holes can bring about
ultimate destruction their supermassive
counterparts can also feed and fuel the
very stuff of stars planets
and life
but many of these supermassive black
holes also leave us
with a mystery
just how did they get so big in the
first place
if they are the seeds of galaxies then
what were their seeds
and finally when and indeed what
were the first
black holes
isaac newton rarely went to sleep before
3 am and worked 18 hour days this worked
for him it won't work for you it's
hugely important to have a healthy
routine and a great way to overcome the
initial inertia is trying out fabulous
the number one self-care app to help you
build better habits and accomplish your
goals and the sponsor of this video with
a community of more than 30 million
users fabulous is a digital coach that
uses methods taken from evidence-backed
behavioral science to help you develop
great habits it will help you create
rituals and reminders throughout the day
that will push you towards your goals
step by step little by little from the
first moment you wake up personally i'd
been hoping to increase my mindfulness
and live a calmer life and fabulous's
great systems have helped me stick to my
goals and not let them drift away and
with fabulous premium you can build and
improve an unlimited number of habits
and routines unlocking all programs and
exercises so start building your ideal
daily routine the first 500 people who
click on the link will get 25 off a
fabulous subscription thanks to fabulous
for supporting education on youtube
rain clutters harshly on the tin roof of
the rudimentary shelter
it is channeled down and collects into
the growing gutter of water that winds
its way through the muddy trench and
past the sodden boots of the young
soldiers who huddle for warmth beneath
the darkening december sky
the gunfire and shelling has mercifully
stopped for now and the senior
lieutenant ducks inside the little
refuge to turn his attention to the pile
of dispatches on the desk
it is 1915 on the eastern front of world
war one and the lieutenant
is karl
svartshield
smartshield is an accomplished theorist
and mathematician and the director of
the astronomical observatory in potsdam
even so the relentless pressures of the
great war see him sign up for the war
effort and squat in his great coat
alongside the harrowed soldiers of the
german army but tonight his attention is
caught by a familiar handwriting on the
wrappings of a bulky envelope instantly
he recognizes it as the hand of his
friend and colleague albert einstein
entitled the field equations of
gravitation the paper within lays out
the mathematical basis for what will
become known as the general theory of
relativity and all of our modern
understanding of gravity on cosmic
scales
incomprehensible to all but the most
involved theorists it describes an
elegant formulae how mata causes
space-time to curve and how space-time
tells mata how to move
svartshield holds the paper in trembling
hands and that evening risks a dim and
flickering electric light to read and
study einstein's work with delight the
circular reasoning of the scholars
equations may be mathematically elegant
but this also makes them notoriously
difficult to solve
smartshield though is grateful for the
distraction and just a matter of days
after receiving einstein's supposedly
impenetrable formulae he writes to his
friend offering the unthinkable
a solution
in the covering letter smartshield
writes
as you see the war treated me kindly
enough in spite of the heavy gunfire to
allow me to get away from it all and
take this walk in the land of your ideas
[Music]
what sfartshield saw on this
relativistic walk was a surprisingly
simple solution which completely
describes how space-time is curved
around a spherical object like a planet
or a star by extension he showed how it
becomes much much harder to escape the
gravity of a small compact and highly
dense star and that by pushing the
limits of density and shrinking the star
even further the curvature becomes so
great that no particle not even the
photons of light can escape
the distance from a given point at which
nothing could escape which would come to
be known eponymously as the swat shield
radius depends on the universal
gravitational constant the speed of
light and the amount of mass that is
concentrated in one place
since both gravitation and the speed of
light are constant the svat shield
radius really only varies with the mass
the more mass
the further the radius extends
for instance the smart shield radius
around a human is around a millionth the
diameter of a single quark
so if you were to be condensed down into
this size the gravity would be enough to
trap you there
forever
around the earth it is around nine
millimeters the sun three kilometers
of course since the actual sizes of
these bodies far exceed their
svartshield radii their mass isn't
concentrated within it and so we see no
bizarre phenomena it is only in the
cases of extremely dense objects
smartshield reasoned that this extreme
space-time curvature would have any
tangible effects
[Music]
smartshield himself survived the gunfire
but soon after succumbed to a skin
disease he contracted while on the front
he didn't live to see how his ideas
would be developed further indeed at the
time many physicists denied that such an
impossibly dense object and its
associated space-time curvature could
really exist
in 1964 two geiger counters were
launched above the atmosphere in a short
rocket flight in order to search for
celestial sources of x-rays which are
normally blocked by our thick blanket of
air these instruments swept across the
sky and pinpointed one such intense
x-ray source in the constellation of
cygnus which became known as sig x-1
puzzlingly at the time the bright x-rays
didn't seem to correspond with any
significant star or body that could be
seen and for several years sig x one's
true nature was a mystery
but later more precise measurements
offered additional evidence to
astronomers growing suspicions
the sources very fast x-ray variability
on time scales less than a second
suggested that the x-ray emitting region
was much smaller than your typical star
and the discovery of a binary companion
allowed the mass of the source to be
calculated from the size of the
companion's orbit
the result
was stunning
sig x1
was smaller than a star
but some 15 times more massive
it far surpassed the theoretical limit
for white dwarfs or neutron stars
leaving svarzshield's light swallowing
singularity the most likely solution
as the mysteries of sig x-1 unraveled
throughout the early 1970s science had
also coined a new name for this
gravitational monstrosity
john weather an american theoretical
physicist took it upon himself to revive
interest in the general theory of
relativity after world war ii and in a
lecture at nasa in 1967 an audience
member sick of hearing him drone the
words gravitationally completely
collapsed object for the umpteenth time
suggested black hole as an alternative
wheeler seized upon this simple and
evocative term
from that moment forward black holes
became the common even household name
[Music]
today we have a good understanding of
how certain black holes like sig x1 come
to be
stars burn hydrogen and helium fuel
until that fuel is exhausted at which
point the heat generated from fusion is
no longer great enough to sustain them
against the gravity that wants to pull
their matter in on itself if the mass of
the dying star is more than about three
times that of our sun then theoretically
there is no force that can stop it
collapsing completely in
much of the outer shell of material may
be exploded outwards in a dramatic
supernova leaving behind an extremely
dense remnant that curves space-time
just as karl schwarzschild predicted
this remnant is surrounded by an event
horizon a point of no return which marks
its new boundary
the edge of the so-called hole which
lives on to swallow any luckless matter
that passes its way
the more matter it swallows
the larger it gradually grows
but still the region inside the event
horizon remains a mystery einstein's
equations suggest that time itself is
destroyed at the center and some
scientists have even suggested that the
singularity actually leads to another
universe altogether
but there is no way we can find out no
experiment we can perform
as nothing can travel faster than the
speed of light nothing is powerful
enough to escape the event horizon
inside this impenetrable boundary
defined by the swat shield radius
everything is unknown
[Music]
nevertheless the process by which
so-called stellar black holes form is
reasonably well understood and
astronomers suspect that some 100
million are lurking in our galaxy alone
but their small size makes them hard to
find and to date we have detected only a
dozen or so of these black objects in
the blackness of space
but they do have siblings
siblings that lurk at the hearts of
every galaxy
siblings that are much more conspicuous
but at the same time
much
much
more mysterious
[Music]
april the 10th 2019 a picture sweeps the
globe instantly becoming a viral
sensation unlike most viral images this
one wasn't visually impressive on its
own it was fuzzy and indistinct an
orange taurus on a plain black
background but it nevertheless
represented the work of hundreds of
scientists over half a decade
just a few weeks later more than a
billion people had laid eyes on the very
thing that physicists had refuted for
years and which most astronomers never
expected to see directly outside of
their imaginations
it was of course
the first ever image of a black hole
[Music]
black holes as their name and very
definition dictate are black
at first glance this makes the prospect
of photographing them seem like a fool's
errand but scientists have seized upon
the voracious nature of these
gravitational chasms and their effects
on the matter that surrounds them
a sufficiently massive black hole
surrounded by a sufficiently large disk
of gas and dust theoretically gives off
enough radiation in the form of high
frequency radio waves to be detected by
a sufficiently large radio telescope
here on earth these black holes needed
to be more than massive they had to be
supermassive the name for a black hole
that weighs millions or even billions of
times that of our sun astronomers
believe that these leviathans reside at
the center of most large galaxies and
indeed may be crucial to the formation
and evolution of the galaxies themselves
as they feed and grow the supermassives
occasionally spit out accelerated globs
of gas counter-intuitively helping stars
to form just at the moment of other's
death the link is so strong that some
astronomers have begun to grapple with
the question of which came first
did the earliest galaxies feed and fuel
supermassive black holes or did the
supermassives already in existence
somehow seed the stars and galaxies of
our modern cosmos
so in searching for the ideal
supermassive candidate the black hole
imaging scientists needed only to turn
to the heart of our own milky way
here the supermassive black hole known
as sagittarius a star looms 25 000 light
years away from earth with a mass of
some 4 million suns
its relative proximity may have made it
an obvious target
but that nearness also brought with it
additional problems
embedded as it is within the milky
streak of stars that give our galaxy its
name there are countless celestial
objects blocking a clear view of the
supermassive black hole
not only that but as the earth turns so
the center of the galaxy sweeps across
the sky each night it would be very
difficult to maintain a telescope fix
for long enough to gather the necessary
data
therefore to begin with the
international team of scientists set
their sights on a more distant
supermassive this time residing at the
center of the messier 87 galaxy in the
virgo cluster
at first this may seem odd m87 is some
55 million light years away far further
than the mere 25 000 light years to
sagittarius a star but its sheer size
made up for the distance
for m87 weighs an incredible
6.5 billion times our sun's mass
also at such a distance it stays
relatively still in the night sky and
there is a clear line of sight all the
way
the next challenge however was to
actually build a telescope that was big
enough to reveal m87s blackened core
in radio astronomy the resolution of the
final image obtained depends on the size
of the telescope aperture that collects
the radio light
this means that for small and distant
objects bigger is always better leading
to some fairly on-the-nose names for
modern high-resolution radio telescopes
[Music]
the giant ukrainian radio telescope the
large millimeter telescope the very
large array but for m87 even very large
was not large enough
the radio telescope would have to be
roughly the size of the entire earth
and so researchers worldwide
collaborated to connect eight radio
telescopes from across the globe forming
a composite telescope with an aperture
that spanned from the south pole to
spain and a resolution around four
thousand times better than the hubble
space telescope
this so-called event horizon telescope
with its component parts synchronized by
atomic clock collected radio waves from
the direction of m87 for four days in
2017. the observations from each
monitoring station were delivered on
physical hard drives since internet
speeds were unable to cope with the
volume of data
two years of intensive data processing
later and the team finally had their
impossible image
a silhouette of the m87 supermassives
black hole event horizon
lit by the radio light of its accretion
disk
but the discoveries didn't stop there in
may 2022 after an additional three years
of processing data from the event
horizon telescope's initial observations
of the milky way were finally resolved
into the second ever image of a black
hole
we finally caught a glimpse of the
beating heart of our own galaxy
sagittarius a star
[Music]
imaging and analysis continues to break
new ground in visualizing and
understanding these supermassive black
holes but there are still so many
unanswered questions surrounding their
lives and crucially their formation
just how does a black hole get to weigh
as much as m87 does
or more
indeed 6.5 billion times the mass of our
sun doesn't even come close to the
largest black hole we've found
ton 618 belonging to a quasar 10.4
billion light years from earth tips the
balance at an incredible
66 billion solar masses
making it a so-called ultra-massive
black hole
it alone is heavier than all the stars
in the milky way combined and with
accretionary winds that reach 20 percent
the speed of light it consumes matter at
such a rate that its luminosity exceeds
that of all the stars in its galaxy
when astronomers detect quasars the
brightest objects in the universe
they are detecting these super or ultra
massive black holes within active
galactic nuclei
they are arguably the most impressive
single objects in the entire cosmos
but how
did they form
some suggest that these heavyweights
started out just as their stellar black
hole cousins a gigantic star lived died
dramatically and left behind a bulky
black hole in its wake
then over a period of billions of years
that gravitational titan got lucky
encountering star after gigantic star to
feed its insatiable hunger growing
gradually until it attained mammoth
proportions and ensnared entire star
systems into stable orbit around it
but critics failed to see how such
growth could be accomplished by gradual
means alone and suggests a much more
staggered approach
instead of a single voracious beast
consuming stars and gas alternative
theories see supermassives born in
mergers between several smaller stellar
mass black holes indeed such mergers
have already been observed by the
gravitational waves that ripple out from
them it would certainly be a shortcut to
acquiring mass but questions remain as
to how likely these binary black hole
encounters are perhaps our continued
observation of the supermassive black
holes in our galactic neighborhood will
help to answer these questions
but there is one overarching mystery
that stands regardless
when we peer back into the distant and
consequently ancient cosmos
we still find
supermassives the ultramassive black
hole ton 618 is nearly 11 billion years
old and many supermassive black holes
have been detected dating back to just a
few million years after the big bang
so if they assembled gradually or
through repeated mergers of stellar
black holes their presence so soon in
the cosmological timeline implies that
innumerable stars have already lived and
died
to form them
and here is where the problem lies
plugging in the masses of these early
supermassives and the well-constrained
estimates of star formation in the
earliest phase of stellar growth
these supermassive black holes
just shouldn't be possible
some giants had grown to 1 billion times
the mass of our sun by less than a
billion years after the big bang but
calculations show that only 100 000
solar masses should be possible a
difference of four orders of magnitude
there is another phenomenon called a
direct collapse black hole that could
offer at least a partial explanation
instead of forming during the death of a
star as with stellar black holes direct
collapse singularities form as their
name suggests directly from the collapse
of material in the early universe but
without any intervening star formation
such early high mass black holes could
be the beginnings of the supermassives
we see today but
they probably aren't the ultimate
solution the conditions for their
formation are so restrictive that they
were like the rare phenomena and not
enough to explain the supermassive
shepherds and their galactic herds that
fill the universe today
there must be
another piece
to the puzzle
lurking back at the dawn of time
there must be something
something that helped to feed these
giants from their birth and help them to
grow into the black behemoths that power
our galaxies today
but what could create a black hole
before stars
are born
when a 20 year old undergraduate student
first fell down the stairs in oxford in
1962 his doctors helpfully told him to
lay off the beer
but when this clumsiness continued into
the next year his family began to worry
and the young scholar was sent to
hospital for a series of tests after two
weeks of rigorous investigations the
physicians still didn't tell the young
man what was wrong with him except that
he was an atypical case and they
expected it
to get worse
reluctant to ask for more details the
young stephen hawking simply took the
vitamins the doctors recommended even
though he could see in their eyes that
they didn't expect them to work
by this time hawking had begun his
postgraduate studies at the university
of cambridge
the medical diagnosis he had avoided
facing was one of amyotrophic lateral
sclerosis or als which sees the motor
neurons in the brain rapidly degenerate
until you are no longer able to
coordinate your movements talk and
eventually swallow and breathe
the doctors predicted the 21 year old
hawking had two years left to live
but stephen hawking defied his doctors
instead of fading away over the next two
years he took his vitamins and kept
fighting for 55 years more
in refusing to surrender to his als
hawking completes his postgraduate
studies becomes an esteemed academic and
eventually a household name
arguably one of the most famous
scientists of all time rivalling the
great charles darwin and albert einstein
and becoming one of the youngest ever
scholars to be elected a fellow of the
royal society
and yet to the public many of whom
failed to grasp the nuances of his
physics he became defined by his als and
his tenacity in overcoming it for so
long
but his science was truly worth the
accolades and fame he received for
during his long and fruitful academic
career hawking transformed our
understanding of the universe's
beginnings
and black holes
his doctoral thesis completed in 1966
under the shadow of his recent diagnosis
focused on the debate that raged at the
time concerning the beginnings of the
universe inspired by the novel physics
of an impossibly dense point at the
center of black holes hawking made a
similar suggestion for the beginning of
the universe itself
throughout the early 1970s he described
and defined the fundamental rules for
black holes including the observation
that an event horizon could never get
smaller later however he attempted to
unite the fundamentally incompatible
theories of general relativity and
quantum mechanics to postulate the
existence of a kind of radiation that
could actually see black holes evaporate
and eventually disappear this hawking
radiation as it became known was a
phenomenon that held up in theory but
had not been seen in practice in any
discovered black hole
hawking continued to grapple with these
problems throughout his entire academic
life but even while he was tackling the
unknowable about modern black holes
stephen hawking's attention was
continually drawn back to the cosmos as
a whole
and in particular
its beginnings
hawking's study of black holes endlessly
informed his research into the
unreachable big bang and his unique
understanding of the universe's first
moments gave him new insights into black
holes
and so in 1971 he popularized a radical
suggestion for which at the time there
was little tangible evidence
he proposed that a new type of black
hole could be found at the beginning of
the universe a so-called primordial
black hole which formed not from dying
stars
but from the birth of the cosmos
itself 13.8 billion years ago the big
bang results in the creation of energy
fields that permeate the cosmos and
which as the universe cools and expands
disentangle into the fields of force
that rule our lives today
further cooling sees the very first
subatomic particles quarks and leptons
spring into existence and be endowed
with properties like mass and charge
which will again come to rule the
physics of the next 13.8 billion years
but the universe is still far too small
hot and turbulent for any real matter as
we know it today to exist
suddenly inflation triggered by as yet
unknown forces sees the universe double
in size around 90 times in 10 million
billion billion billionths of a second
tiny variations in quantum energy
throughout the minuscule
pre-inflationary universe are now almost
instantaneously transformed into vast
regions of inhomogeneity
all over this inflated universe there
are variations in the density of
particles and energy that will provide
the seeds for the overall structure of
the cosmos many billions of years later
but stephen hawking also foresaw another
consequence of these density variations
over newly expanded space
where there is stuff
there is gravity and these denser
regions begin to curve the fabric of
space-time on a macroscopic scale for
the very first time
according to hawking the response to
this sudden and spontaneous shift was
for the denser patches to begin to
tumble into their own gravitational
wells collapsing in on themselves due to
gravity and in doing so exponentially
increasing their own gravitational
potential
as this runaway gravitational collapse
continues the fundamental stuff of the
universe is compressed into the
mathematically infinitely dense
singularity which captures all
the singularity is cloaked in an event
horizon and the newborn particles are
locked away for eternity before spending
even one full second in the universe
[Music]
all over the freshly expanded cosmos
primordial black holes appear at the
hearts of the densest patches of nascent
mata
mathematically there is only a very
brief window after the big bang in which
the primordial black holes could have
formed when the universe is reached one
second old expansion and cooling has
already rendered the cosmos too large
and too calm to allow spontaneous
gravitational singularities to appear
but prior to this point there is no
physical reason why primordial black
holes couldn't have filled the embryonic
cosmos
hawking and others calculated that the
later in this one second window that the
gravitational collapse occurred the
larger the primordial black hole would
be this means that they could range in
size from anywhere from one one hundred
thousandth the mass of a paperclip up to
one hundred thousand times the mass
of the sun
but here
lies
the problem
like so much of stephen hawking's work
his elegant mathematics are watertight
but it leaves us with little in the way
of testable hypotheses
how do you go about proving that
primordial black holes did or didn't
exist
we must find a way to detect them or at
least detect their tangible effects on
the early evolution of the universe but
when we don't know how numerous they
were exactly when they formed and
exactly what size they're likely to be
then searching for the earliest black
holes is tantamount to finding a needle
in the cosmological haystack
[Music]
mercury venus earth mars jupiter saturn
uranus and neptune
the eight major planets of our solar
system
some have been observed since the second
millennium bc seen and studied with the
naked eye others have been spotted by
telescope or predicted based on their
effects on other objects and
subsequently discovered right where we
expected them to be
but there may yet be one more object
left to find even after 4 000 years of
astronomical study there are mysteries
lurking on our celestial doorstep
in 1951 gerard kuiper an astronomer and
professor at the university of chicago
contemplated a cometary conundrum
scientists had long observed so-called
short period comets icy bodies which
swing through the solar system on
elongated orbits passing close to earth
and the sun every 200 years or less
halley's comet which was last visible to
the naked eye in 1986 and will revisit
us again in 2061 is one such visitor but
its flybys won't last forever every time
the comet passes close to the sun it
evaporates more of its icy core and
after a few more orbits it will be lost
completely to nebulous interplanetary
space
but by this reasoning after the four and
a half billion years that our solar
system has been around there shouldn't
be any more short period comets left
unless kuiper reasoned there was a
nursery of icy bodies far out in the
outer solar system beyond the orbit of
neptune a belt filled with orbiting
chunks of ice could be disturbed by the
gravity of neptune and the other giant
planets flinging ice blocks in towards
the sun to become comets on a swinging
death spiral that lasts thousands or
even millions of years
despite kuiper's early predictions it
wasn't until 1992 that evidence for this
belt of icy objects was actually
discovered nasa scientists spotted the
first one and then many more of these
so-called trans-neptunian objects
and the space they occupied became known
as the kuiper belt
but as the inventory of kuiper belt
objects grew another conundrum presented
itself
there were some that seemed to behave
quite strangely
one a dwarf planet named sedna
discovered in 2003 has a very long
extremely elliptical orbit that takes
more than ten thousand years to complete
and even at its closest approach sedna
is still two and a half times further
from the sun than neptune there is
simply no way that neptune could be
responsible for setting off this huge
motion other extreme trans-neptunian
orbits also show a surprising pattern
clustering to one side of the solar
system and tilted deeply below the
equatorial plane statistically such a
distribution is extremely unlikely in
the absence of external influences these
objects orbits should randomize over 100
million years
and so in 2012 a brazilian astronomer
named rodney gomez suggested an
explanation for these bizarre orbital
patterns
that there was in fact an external
influence in the form of a distant
massive planet that shepherds them
around
that hypothetical planet has come to be
known
as planet
nine
by the orbital calculations planet nine
would be around six times the mass of
the earth traveling on an elongated and
tilted orbit around four hundred times
further from the sun than the earth's
own orbit but despite knowing this and
searching specifically for it with the
highest resolution instruments we
possess astronomers haven't found a
trace of this neptune-sized planet
critics have counted that the anomalous
orbits could be the result of
observational bias shaped by how and
where we can search for kuiper belt
objects and that planet nine doesn't
really exist
jim greene nasa's chief scientist at the
time quoted carl sagan saying
extraordinary claims require
extraordinary evidence
and there is another tantalizing
possibility
another even more extraordinary claim
what if planet nine has all the
characteristics scientists have
calculated the mass the distance the
orbit but is something much much
smaller
the first detected primordial black hole
to begin with positing a black hole
instead of a planet would help to
explain why this gravitational shepherd
has been so difficult to detect with a
mass equivalent to six earths a
gravitationally collapsed black hole's
event horizon would be approximately the
size of a tennis ball not only would it
be completely black but set against the
vastness of space it would be almost
impossibly tiny too
of course theorizing primordial black
holes in our galactic neighborhood is
one thing actually detecting these tiny
but potent objects is quite another
some suggest that their intense gravity
would be enough to attract a micro halo
of dark matter just as entire galaxies
are thought to be enveloped in a dark
matter halo on a massive scale so by
searching for the dark matter and its
associated radiation in the direction of
planet nine we might hope to distinguish
planet from black hole and in doing so
provide evidence for the early evolution
of the universe itself
and yet this methodology depends very
much on the theoretical assumptions of
what exactly dark matter is and how it
behaves which is by no means resolved
dark matter is so named because although
it makes up some 27 percent of the
universe as a whole and outweighs normal
matter by some six to one we have never
been able to detect it directly it
is dark invisible to every instrument we
have yet invented
two camps suggest two different options
for the identity of dark matter
wimps
and machos
wimps or weakly interacting massive
particles are a subatomic particle that
interacts with the universe via gravity
but does not otherwise fit into the
standard model of particle physics
on the other hand machos are massive
astrophysical compact halo objects and
are theorized as heavy astronomical
bodies that could explain the
gravitational effects in dark matter
halos
stephen hawking himself was among the
first to suggest that the primordial
black holes he predicted could be a type
of macho thereby making up some if not
all of the missing matter if so the dark
matter that holds the universe together
is not only dark because it is unknown
but because it is dark by its very
essence
primordial black holes become tiny
pinpricks in the fabric of space-time
which when clustered around galaxies
help to keep swarms of billions of stars
in check the combined mass of primordial
black holes formed in the first second
of the universe could be enough to
outnumber normal matter it is perhaps a
sobering thought that possibly only a
sixth of matter that came into existence
at the birth of the universe escaped
immediate imprisonment behind an eternal
event horizon
how then
would you detect a primordial black hole
one toolkit depends on another of
stephen hawking's predictions
hawking radiation
this is thought to be produced at the
event horizon of all black holes when
quantum particle interactions are
subjected to general relativity
the result of this is that black holes
emit a kind of gamma-ray glow and will
shrink over time as they undergo
something like evaporation not only that
but hawking predicted that the smaller a
black hole's event horizon the faster it
will evaporate leading to an exponential
emission that ultimately produces an
explosion any black hole that was less
than 10 to the power 11 kilograms in
mass would be expected to decay on a
time scale shorter than the age of the
universe so we could search for their
swan songs across the night
sky the fermi gamma-ray telescope which
has been circling our planet in low
earth orbit since 2008 is well equipped
to search for these gamma-ray explosions
but the results of nearly 15 years of
observation
have not been promising and here is a
key piece of evidence or lack thereof
the absence of hawking radiation
outbursts suggests that statistically
less than one percent of dark matter
could be composed of these tiny
primordial black holes
there is always the possibility that
stephen hawking's theory was somehow
incorrect and that hawking radiation and
the associated explosions don't actually
occur indeed the conclusions are based
on a mathematical house of cards with no
robust data points to glue anything in
place
but other possible detection methods are
rooted in more traditional orbital
mechanics and observed phenomena the
fermi gamma-ray telescope has the
ability to search for gamma rays from
other sources not just from potential
primordial black holes if those gamma
rays from say pulsing neutron stars or
supernovas flicker unexpectedly then
this may be due to gravitational lensing
as a primordial black hole passes by
still however the results are not
promising both gamma-ray and optical
astronomy have failed to find convincing
evidence of any black hole flybys and
the statistics based on the duration of
the survey and number of candidate
discoveries puts a limit on the numbers
of primordial black holes out there that
weigh a certain amount
and based on this it's very unlikely
that earth size or smaller black holes
are the hidden machos that make up dark
matter
other clues have been sought but are
similarly lacking it's expected that the
gravitational wells of wandering
primordial black holes would be able to
capture other dense objects like neutron
stars and white dwarfs leading to their
ultimate destruction but the fact that
these stars still exist in great numbers
puts yet another limit on the possible
number of primordial black holes that
have been hanging around for the last
13.8 billion years even probing the
cosmic past for traces of these early
phenomena leaves us wanting the
existence of primordial black holes so
soon after the big bang would have led
to an accretion of mata early in its
history early enough that it might be
expected to create recognizable signals
in the pattern of the cosmic microwave
background radiation but analyses of
that universal scale fingerprint reveal
no signposts to early black holes
at least those between 100 and 10 000
times the mass of our sun
if they existed then they were too small
to leave a scar
since stephen hawking first popularized
the idea of primordial black holes in
1971 astronomers have tried to think
outside the box to try and find ways to
verify or refute his hypothesis
for the most part they have yielded
little in the way of positive results
and for a time the future of primordial
black hole theory
looked bleak
that was
until 2015
when the brand new ligo instrument in
the united states detected gravitational
waves that were traced back to the
collision of two black holes each with a
mass 30 times that of our sun this
detection alone was exciting and
confirmation that gravitational waves
were not only real and detectable but
could also be a useful tool in probing
the distant universe
but the implications of what they'd
found had black hole scientists excited
for an entirely different reason black
holes with 30 solar masses are too big
to have been formed by conventional
stellar death
and yet they are too small to be
explained by supermassive black hole
mechanisms either
is there another possible explanation
primordial black holes
could very well be it
if most primordial black holes had a
similar mass then calculations of how
often they would meet and collide seem
to match the frequency of collisions now
being detected by ligo
and so finally a measurable result seems
to be breathing new life into the old
black holes
the earlier negative results hadn't
altogether ruled out the possibility of
primordial black holes but rather put
stricter limits on what masses they're
likely to be such limits probably rule
them out as the sole source of the
universe's dark matter but the case on
their formation and influence is by no
means closed
and the mass ranges that still haven't
been explored by current observational
techniques do offer a tantalizing
possibility
indeed simulations that replace all of
the assumed dark matter with primordial
black holes of 1.4 solar masses show us
that they could play a major role in the
early evolution of the universe
including seeding the first stars
galaxies and supermassive black holes
the question of whether when and how
primordial black holes formed and
evolved in the first second of the
universe
is still one of the biggest mysteries in
cosmology today and a topic that
continues to attract speculation and
experimentation
scientists hopes lie in the newest and
most advanced instruments such as the
james webb telescope which will image
the earliest stars and galaxies and
attempt to corroborate theories of
primordial black hole seeding or lisa
the laser interferometer space antenna a
space-based gravitational wave detector
planned to launch next decade which may
be able to search for ripples from black
hole mergers of likely primordial size
directly
there is still much to learn about the
first black holes but as stephen hawking
realized understanding them offers the
opportunity to unlock the secrets of the
cosmos
primordial black holes if they do exist
may hold the key to our universe's
earliest moments
the nature of dark matter the driving
forces between supermassive black holes
and the evolution of galaxies stars
and ultimately
us
you've been watching the entire history
of the universe don't forget to like and
subscribe and leave a comment to tell us
what you think
thanks for watching and we'll see you
next time
[Music]